[Musique]
d'abord voilà je suis sûr qu'ils savent
pas très longtemps j'ai appris à lire
mais je me suis lancé un défi je vais
lire ce soir je m'amuse toujours comme
toujours
connaissez vous le 3e arrondissement de
marseille pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas je vous en parlais je vous en
parlais comment j'en suis sorti aussi
mon sort pour commencer je suis design
robert jeunes comédiens et j'ai tout
d'abord vous parler de mon enfance à
l'âge de 7 ans et demi huit ans j'ai
déménagé dans mon petit quartier pour
aller dans le 3e arrondissement
j'ai fait plusieurs écoles j'étais
souvent renvoyés c'était pas très facile
des écoles là bas c'est pas les
meilleures écoles là bas ils commencent
à faire des connaissances j'étais
inscrit dans différents clubs de sport
j'ai commencé à faire des conneries
moment et comment ça a tourné dans le
quartier à l'âge de 16 ans et demi j'ai
été incarcéré
j'ai fêté mes 17 ans là bas c'est là que
j'ai rencontré et médine éducatrice qui
s'occupait de mon projet de sortie chez
kstr si je suis même pas qu'on remercie
elle m'appelle m'a parlé d'un film qui
se tourne à marseille a la base je
voulais être car l'air mais emilie avec
je préparais mon projet de sortie à
pousser le dossier en mettant en mettant
le casting dans le projet de sortie pour
mai dentaire sortir plus tôt elle
pensait que ça allait mais d après avoir
été libéré gt gt au casting j'ai
rencontré sandrine lapuyade la
directrice de casting
elle m'a rappelé je rencontrais
jean-bernard marlins le réalisateur du
film
c'est là qu'il m'a dit qu'on passe dans
l'atelier théâtre je savais qu'elle fait
quel personnage allait interpréter le
rôle de cinq ans répétitions je revois
15 ans fort tu as une connaissance que
d'enfance que j'avais déjà vu mon style
perdu de vue puis j'ai dit vas-y je vais
me lancer je n'avais jamais essayé la
caméra je me lance et puis au bout de
plusieurs reprises la première prison me
demander de courir et ça j'ai dit vas-y
se fait des pompes et où je me lance j'y
vais et je devais rejoindre mes
collègues et tout ça ils viennent ça se
passe plus de plusieurs prix jeu j'étais
bon plus en plus j'en faisais au plus
juste et bon comme en interview et j'ai
fini le tournage
et puis je suis parti à revenir ma peine
en prison et c'est là que en prison j'en
entends parler tout je me dis j'entends
je me dis ouah ça spi prendre la place
mon film j'ai un temps la semaine de la
critique de cannes et tout ça et je me
dis [ __ ] ça ça ça s'peut store et de
ça il ya moyen je sors la vie tu vois et
et puis et puis et puis et puis et puis
oui je suis libérables je suis
libérables et tout ça et je passe des
barreaux tapis rouge pète les plombs je
me refais un deuxième film dans ma tête
et c'est pas fini
tout de suite après fait de festival en
festival je reçois je reçois une
invitation pour les révélations des
césar je dis moi c'est magnifique c'est
elodie bouchez en plus ma marraine et
puis après j'arrive aux césar j'entends
j'entends le nôtre kenza pour meilleur
espoir féminin
si tu vois c'est quelque chose d y en a
et un césar pour shérazade et puis il
arrive le meilleur espoir masculin remis
par caen mise à jour des normes plus et
quand j'entends mon nom je ne crois même
pas ré choqué je prends des grandes
claques tout le monde me crie dessus
mais lève toi lève toi et tout j'arrive
pas à me lever et puis et puis je prends
mon courage à deux mains je vais vers
kad merad et comme ils un jour donne
hakim félicite
et puis des singes prendre je prends mon
césar jeudi ce qui me sort du coeur et
tout ça je descends avec mon césar est
ça un peu sonné j'écoutais ce qui se
passait là bas
et j'entends le meilleur espoir premier
film jean-bernard marlins tu vois on a
eu trois césar on a fait un braquage à
la marseillaise j'ai pété les plombs
j'ai dis ouah c'est un truc de fou
pendant ce temps là j'écris j'ai cru
pendant longtemps que c'est un coup de
chance le fruit du hasard je me suis
rendu compte maintenant que c'est c'est
une question de rencontres ouais mais
aussi de volonté dans vue de saisir les
chances qui me sont donnés de tout
donner pour y arriver donc allez-y
foncez rêver
[Applaudissements]